en chine c'est l'été le plus chaud
jamais enregistré depuis le début des
relevés il ya 61 ans dans le sud ouest
du pays les habitants de chongqing une
ville de 31 millions d'habitants sont
très éprouvés par la canicule il fuit la
chaleur accablante en trouvant refuge
dans les centres commerciaux et dans le
métro la sécheresse également frappe
cette région et les températures ont pu
atteindre 45 degrés même si l'efficacité
de cette pratique n'est pas prouvée à
100% abu dhabi il croit puisque chez eux
la nature est avare en eau autant la
brusquer un peu pour obtenir
satisfaction alors en quoi consiste ce
programme d'ensemencement envoyé des
avions se faufiler dans les nuages deux
à trois fois par semaine il se met des
produits chimiques comme de iodure
d'argent censé attirer des gouttelettes
et espérer enfin que les gouttes est
s'alourdissent pour tomber sur terre
sous forme de plus quel long short à
dire son nom d'un archipel de l'océan
atlantique
hamas
[Applaudissements]
mais oui ma langue fourche avec
les gens que tu es une belle paire de
bas hamas pour qu'il gratifie d humains
d'une pluie les aztèques ont l'habitude
de sacrifier des enfants jusque là rien
de très original sauf que il faut qu'on
les sacrifie pas n'importe comment il
faut les faire pleurer comme la loque
pleure la pluie sur le monde c'est à
dire beaucoup alors les enfants on va
les noyer mais avant desnoyers on va
leur arracher les ongles les dents et
les yeux s pratique de pleurer sans dieu
je ne sais pas
là sa mère la chèvre à la honte frères
ils n'arrivent pas à les passer les
vitesses
j'ai changé chaud maintenant une ficelle
avec cd ou alors
ma première femme à donner notre fils
aîné habiba ma mère est ma seconde femme
à donner notre premier enfant à sa mère
à elle
ça veut dire que ta maman est à la fois
la grand mère et la mère de ton fils
oui abîmer mon fils et mon frère
monsieur l'a trouvé trop belle pour lui
selon ce qu'il m'a confiées donc
monsieur ne bougeait pas manqué d'humour
madame à trouver le temps long
et a donc pris les devants alors
attention monsieur parce que madame
ménard à 14 février et si vous ne le
savez pas saint valentin est mort
décapité
moralité l'amour c'est perdre la tête
on peut noter un rigolo non j'adore bon
je vais pas commencer un suisse qui a
inventé ça oui et donc ça challenge son
conjoint une note quoi par exemple on
peut lui demander tient vas-y passe
l'aspirateur après tu notes le résultat
il ya plein de thématiques la famille
les enfants le sexe à la nuit dernière
un ou deux hommes ne se sentant plus
responsables vont dire ben je m'occupe
de moi je veux pas je vois pas pourquoi
je m'occuperai je partagerai les tâches
avec une femme avec un enfant je me
débrouille très bien tout seul je serai
je j'organiserai une ville peu mais
j'aurai peu d'efforts à faire et je
vivrai qu'une petite bande de copains
avec la barre très bas est ce que tu es
marié
à 20 ans et j'ai deux femmes
en même temps
et bientôt
j'aurai mon premier enfant là c'est pour
ce pur maintenant oui dans quelques
jours tu sais que nous on choisit une
femme dans notre vie pourquoi vous ne
vous mariez pas avec plusieurs femmes et
ça c'est un risque qu'on voit apparaître
il est pas majoritaire mon loi à
paraître surtout aux états unis surtout
au japon pour japon ce phénomène de
société actuellement où les garçons
décrochent dans 30% des cas pas de sam
pas l'enfant par relations sexuelles
c'est pas le bonheur mais c'est ils sont
soulagés de ne pas se ne pas être
responsable fatiha vos coordonnées vos
coordonnées
ok démasqué
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti
ça marche ça marche ça marche un
sens
[Musique]
regardez cette belle image celle du
rocher de gibraltar couverts par ce qui
donne l'impression d'être un nuage de
fumée l'air marin humide et transporté
vers ce relief et s'élève l'humidité
il contient se condense le vent d'est
fait le reste et régale bien sûr les
photographes